hi everyone that the is my pleasure to
be here and really appreciate you taking
the time today to you know listen to the
story of lime so today I want to go to
you're going to be sharing with you the
best story and a journey of lime which
is 21 months you're 21 months old
company that we're really a young
company but in the topic today is not
about just live the topic is about a lot
of Impossibles that impossible of a
company can do well and it dude good at
the same time the impossible you know
scenario of how a company have really
really fast well that you know not crash
in cities or you know do the face that
the cities will community doesn't want
it and I think that your story is about
you know can we reinvent the the urban
transportation right that can we you
know build a step by step towards what a
modern urban transportation will look
like and can we fight against all the
challenges we have you know commonly in
the city so think the you know you
notice there a lot of people have heard
about line there are not many that have
tried it if it is due to you know
availability issues that in a cities you
living or working but we're walking on
out so we also shared on that first of
all right the micro trend of
urbanization that is you know that is
non stoppable and I think that trend is
going to happen regardless what and then
the second part that comes with it is
the the traffic's and the pollution that
everyone experience on a daily basis
and some choose to ignore it but it's
happening and I think that it we're just
getting worse and worse and when we look
at globally daddy you know in terms of
the traffic and pollution Zoar that the
in the past the solution is to throw
more car at it right let's build a more
Road let's throw more cars at it that
doesn't solve the problem you actually
make it worse I think well I've been
living in a you know pay area for about
15 years I can clearly notice how to
change you know has been happening over
time
and many of the you know the audience
probably experience the same but then
when we look at it you know what is the
most efficient way to get a run for the
first and last mile if you look at the
data shows that 70% of the traffic in
the you in the u.s. it's a single
occupancy and also that you know 50%
plus of the more or less than a mile and
you put that two together
now do we really need to drive a
seven-seater SUV to you know get around
go to work or just buy groceries or even
just grab a coffee and the answer
probably is no it's not about only just
the cost is about pollutions is about
shared space how we can utilize them is
about the cost-effectiveness and it is
also a matter of fact that about how we
connect to the communities how do we
connect with each other how we stay
healthier active at a more social and
you know for me that something went
wrong I grew up in China and bike was a
form of transportation for us to get
around and you know not only in in high
school but also in college and even when
after I moved here as to owns like about
eight to nine different bikes I get
around any time I could on a bike and
that's my form of transportation right
and is that only in to for China which
is known for the kingdom of bicycle then
we look around the globe
that's UK that's Amsterdam that's
Copenhagen that's many other places
that's like an alternative
transportation is a norm of
transportation but why that is not a
case in the u.s. if we're looking at
Amsterdam or Copenhagen they're
definitely leading a trend with 30 40 %
of the year transportations on our own
bikes and alternative modes of
transportation and in the US the number
is 1% right that 1% number you know then
we can ask ourselves right
is it weather here worse than Amsterdam
is the road here narrower than Amsterdam
and what is the reason what to stop us
from etapa more
cars and cultures and that's the only
thing it's not that we're you know that
the there's no you know it's not there's
a real blocker from us together then is
really perceptions cultures cars and do
we embrace it and then we look at it you
know what are the things that we can
help users can help our community to get
over the hurdle now the way to convince
them to use it or topped it it's not
like say you're doing noble thing
therefore you have to put in you know
twice as high the price and it do twice
as much effort to make it happen the
better way to convince people is - why
don't we provide you a service a
solution that's faster and the cheaper
and more convenient that is the way that
we think this will generate a massive
behavior shift that really make it
happen
right our goal is not about 1% bike
traffic in the US that how much market
share we can get i will go is that how
we push that one percent to 10 percent
to 20 you know there we say to 50
percent of the traffic and that's the 50
percent of the traffic in the US city
today less than one mile and it's single
occupancy there's no reason we cannot do
that other than we're walking together
so we start in mind when we look at the
market right that the first air last
mile is you know from a business
perspective that we if we won't have a
business that's sustainable that can
really push for big vision and big goals
it has to have the economic you know
foundation for it so we look at the
market is there a market is there you
know big enough to support it or Rd goes
into it or the efforts and what a team
are going to build and is there a market
that you know that a user are feeling
that pain point on a daily basis and
that is the 300 million trip on a daily
basis in the US that we're talking about
and just as a reference that orient left
doing about 10 million trips on a daily
basis and this is a market that we're
looking at it you're 30 ads bigger than
not so when we get started right that we
were called many times over
it was yeah you know some of us say out
the sea has been tried before I had
nobody use it but is that really user
don't wanna use it or is that a product
design the technology available at the
time or the pricing point doesn't make
sense and you know city bikes and
therefore bike a how many tried Ford
bike okay how much you paid for it it's
ten dollars a day right you know of nine
or ten dollars a day in New York is it a
little bit more expensive why you walk a
couple blocks trying to take a back out
of it out of the dark and also you have
to walk a couple blocks when you get
there and return it and pay more than
over it just doesn't make sense and
that's on top of that you probably also
realize you paid for it already since
that's 50 million tax dollars to build a
thing any only CBD area right if you're
in the neighborhoods good luck you will
never find one and so those are things
that it's not user don't wanted it's the
product at a time was not ready for a
massive adoption it's the design of the
system for the convenience and the
pricing point that's it's not there so
when we start a company with focus on
the 3/8 I made it simple for my team the
accessibility availability and
affordability if one of that is not
there we cannot expect a user willing to
pay you know twice as it's more
expensive but then then a would be right
in order to support it that's just not
logical so those are the three things we
work on and to solve that problem and
the second part is I doesn't well you
know the business model will never work
that the idea what burn money like hell
but we validate that wrong too I think
for the for the right product right
experience and also the efficiency we
provided to the users values are more
than happy to pay so you probably notice
a few things that you know there are a
lot of a social media post about line
right at you probably see online or
Twitter on instagrams you know on
Facebook or not right
you know raise your hand if you saw a
single user cell I'm Prada gets too
expensive
they're just not you know that is
amazing saying that we delivered over 20
million trips ever since we launched the
first market yet you see one person say
Lima is too expensive and also user are
really embracing it by not only writing
it also share on all kinds of you know
social medias that the fun they have the
the time they save the efficiency that
they generated and also you know kind of
like the memory to record as a kid or
the the proudness of that it contributed
to saving the traffic and then and also
you know the other you know to reduce
the pollutions right what is the last
time you saw someone jumping in a rubra
to take a selfie raise your hand I think
that's the difference that we're
providing the value but also be young
that we help the user achieve
recognizing that also contributing to
reducing the traffic and contributing
till reducing the pollution and that is
what we proud of as a company it's not
only involve life it's the movement were
generating and the yes dia you know some
of the perception some of the culture
behavior ship that we hope to push
forward and the third saying that yep
you know the end of tree on the trees
there like it did happen in different
marques we got we found our bikes as
scooters and of like all kinds of
different things but I think that's a
challenge that there's always the small
percentage of bad actors that would do
crazy things you know should we be
deterred from it should we punish the 99
percent by you know just owning the
damage done by the one percent we as a
company that we think it's the only
right thing to do it's all focused on
the majority of the good actors rather
than punish everyone because of there's
one percent that act out there we will
be punished by that you know a lot of
system designed in the ward is not about
how do we give the 99 percent good
actors the good you know the past
experience and it's the most efficient
Deanna
most value-adding experience is decide
to prevent that 1% and everyone else got
punished so data I think it can be sold
by technologies we can further improve
on that and that could be further solved
by Education's I'll give you one example
of that we all went through the security
check at the airport right that the I'm
not saying we should take passage about
get don't get me wrong but the reality
is five being all the good actors by
participating in the program unity' it's
ensure that we're all safe we are
punished by the potentially 1% of bad
actor out there it's necessary for us to
ensure the safety and the security of
that but that means we line up every
single one of us went through the
security check the back checks and take
off your shoes take your belt it's not
you know we're all published punished by
that so I think there are good reason
for the system to be in place but you
know okay start you know can we solve it
by technology by sensors by the textures
by self use you know user reports or
that rather than make it rather
difficult to use just like the talk
based system it's not a good user
experience II it doesn't take you to a
destinations if you cannot return to the
dark you God you know penalties and by
being a good actor so then we look at
what do we do right that we as a company
we did a started as a bike share company
or scooter share company we tried and
tested all kinds of products and to
feeding the different user cases so we
started with bike we added bikes to it
and then we launched the scooters and
now we're going to launch the shared
cars and to accommodate the for user
cases of a use need and this is the way
that we see that you know we as a
company not a product company but we're
rather a user company until provided
what a user needed and it always will be
you know free-floating take you end to
end and it also will be much cost
effective so again goes back to the
three C's that we focus on very
accessible and very available and also
very
and this is the way that you know we we
create a value for the users and
convince them that you know this is the
right thing to do rather than you know
wait okay you spend twice as more in
order to support it because we are good
company I I don't think that's a logical
way to do business and that there you go
the the three A's will focus on and the
and also data for the company the the
mission for the company that I
summarized a three years i simplifying
everything so my tow team will easy to
remember that you know my goal is that
any employee of lime you ask them the
question they will give you an answer
immediately so the three es in our
mission in this mission statement is
efficiency eco-friendly and also
enjoyable so we do the things that you
make three things happen at the same
time and here is a animation of how we
power the city of Paris the you know we
not only connect the entire city
together this is the render of sixteen
hours so we're not only connecting them
all together but also that we cover a
lot of neighborhoods are traditionally
considered as transportation desert
there's no public service you know over
driver doesn't want to go there and all
kinds of things and same as many other
cities we launched with so we're not a
just a replacement of the cars I'll user
take but also we're a complementary
system to the existing you know system
they are in Paris alone that we were
powering over thirty thousand trips on a
daily basis and the in the phone factory
is that we launched over twelve
countries in the last three months and
you know newsela is one of the market
very interesting we're app store ranking
number one in New Zealand and it took us
24 hours to cater that without my
without any marketing literally we
launched and we're number one and we
stay number one ever since so that's how
user wanted right not by attracted by
marketing but really by their their
daily need and daily demand and out of
the out of the use cases that 34% of our
users are using it to replace car trips
that they would otherwise that are using
a car you know either driving their
their own car or using a car share
service and out of the seventeen percent
are replacing the public transit but
also this is not entirely and replacing
we also helped increasing the
utilization on the public transit
because we have the solution for the
first air last mile which is the biggest
challenge for public transit and forty
percent of our users end up or started
from public transit
so it's a very complementary to the
system and 37 percent data use that who
replace long walking you know that this
one is a little bit debatable is that
really good feel bad but I would say
though user choose to use them that is
to save time and that time could be
shifted to do other things like
exercising so it's a better option for
the user to optimizing their daily daily
working at the end also time and then
the other part of that is you know you
in terms of like the walk inside for the
person is on a person's aside right this
is a man can never be monetized before
there's an entire blue ocean that you
know never be monetized before it's not
because it cannot be monetized is
there's no right prodding and business
model to do that but the last piece is a
little bit controversial right maybe
when it comes to transportation were
just lazy we just want to get there
instead of putting the work maybe that's
you know not a right way to put it but I
think that the we are not here to
determine how user lived our life we're
here to provide options for them to
choose from and that's the option that
we choose we we provided it doesn't not
prohibit the user from walking but it
does provide an option if you won't get
there faster right to me today you know
that's one of the thing that I struggle
on a daily basis when I user Francisco
running between the meetings and and
come to the public transit so we
launched the first market in June last
year and we're roughly about one year a
four month yes in ever since we launched
the first market and now we're in over a
hundred
markets and as I mentioned that we're in
12 12 countries already and we're you
know rank really high in autumn are in
order
almost or the dear countries we launched
with and this is a based on zero
marketing so we don't even have a
internal you know marketing team right a
lot of people ask me what is your cat
right anyway your entrepreneurship daddy
knows what CAC is right okay so what is
your cost of acquisition MA my answer is
zero we don't have a user acquisition
cost but I think that is the really
focusing on the the real world challenge
that I really focus on the value addicts
is the best user acquisition strategy we
are we generate over twenty million
trips as I mentioned and we're
generating and you know users and trips
way faster than you know a girl lived or
whoever it is in the past and in terms
of the revenues that we're probably one
of the first ever growing company in
history so you compare from the market
lunch to you know first hundred million
two hundred million three hundred
million revenues that's the projection
that's what we got so far that's the
precision projection looks like again
that this is on top of that we didn't
even spend marketing dollars to acquire
users the mission for the four line
again that is not a back shear company
in other shared scooter company but a
more a urban living you know platform if
you would I think T when we come when it
comes to you technology how that will
impact our life right there's always the
left and right at the base on
technologists adding values technology
is taking away our social time
technology is you know drawn us into the
digital media's and forget about family
and all that stuff and attention that
are all we do is about online life I am
proud of that experience learn a lot
from it of online therefore the things
we're doing here is all about how we
leverage technology to in
power users real war lives to make it
better
you're more connected well educated
informed more efficient more enjoyable
and more eco friendly so we started with
transportation data you know you guess
user from A to B but user go out for a
reason right you don't go out just full
go out you got to work you got to school
to lunch to dinner to meeting friends to
bars to coffee to groceries and the next
step for us is how do we help them to
conduct that piece you know in terms of
the user being more informed be you know
connected and also more much more again
more efficient and more enjoyable and
that will be the next chapter for lime
you know in terms of the product roadmap
and this are just some of the photos
from our users all over the place that
you probably find millions of them
online and when it comes to you or to
printer ship that I that was the only
slide I did so when I when it was ok up
kind of speak here you know I would do
one slide right and then what does a
slide will look like and that's the
slide the slide is that ok what do we do
things differently well I think not
necessarily differently from every
single other companies but you know slip
different out if we think that'll help
us to I really get so far where we add
focus on a long term that determines how
we make these issues and determine is
that how we do things start a little bit
I won't say abnormal but we take always
a harder path there are we don't hack
things we don't take shortcuts we're a
company were proud of that we are a
company without shortcuts that you know
building the scooter for example and
also bikes that all the other companies
just buy off-the-shelf product right
literally you place the order you have
Amazon Prime tomorrow you have the
scooter you can launch and it took us
you know much longer time to build a
computer you know hardware that is long
lasting extra safe and also that is more
durable and it's good for the users good
for the users and good for the cities is
we have more advanced sensor on it and
we can you know detect the scooter fail
over we can know what
they are and we can make sure that a
fleet is well maintained and also the
patterning experience for the user
that's much safer it's a much harder
path that we took and we did it and you
know when it comes to CD or the wise
devices we got at a time is hey Wilbur
got a clay book alright why don't we
just go here and just dump millions of
scooters on the street and you know we
not market right argue about that later
and we didn't really didn't do that it's
a harder pass it took us six months to
get at the first market you know a CD
agree upon that and as give us the
permit to launch that is another had a
hard path that we took and there are
many examples like that now that I think
that you know when it focus on the long
term that really help us to decide what
is the right thing to do and to do the
right things right that's what part of
it and I think that is very critical for
us ill or the matter of any companies
right that you know how do we know what
the things to write or not many cases in
many cases we know it's right or what we
know it's wrong but if we don't look at
it from a long-term perspective you
could be very tempting there are a lot
of things are very tempting if you look
at it short term why it's but long term
why's that you know is wrong so I think
that is the one of the principles for
the company where we make decisions that
we always tended to to take the harder
path tended to ignore some so-called
best practices out there it's not
because we're starving it's that we
focus on a long term and then the second
thing is that do the right things as I
mentioned right we did a few other
things before whoever that role of you
know city bike and for biking in the
past or whatever bike rentals or scooter
rental in the past you were never
insured and that was a surprise come to
us when I was used in research in
industry the whole industry has been
around the bike industry has been
running for about 200 years the bike
rental business has been around roughly
about 200 years nobody in sure the users
and we look at it legally no that's not
required right afford you know other
historical reason that
that ensures is not required for bike
rentals and in scooter riders but is
that the right thing to do I don't think
so
so we were the first one actually bought
insurance for our users to champion that
in the entire industry now it becomes
more and more a standard for every
single company that follows into it they
should provide insurance you know do we
occur more cost right we can't even find
a a underwriter you know when we talk to
the insurance company they were like
what are you talking about right there's
no such a thing in the history we never
ride on the ride a bike rental insurance
it just never be required and nobody
proactively provided and we did right we
provided also cash payment for the
non-smartphone
the non non banking users and analysis
shows we're not going to make any money
out of it but that's the right thing to
do and same as like you know why we
further he has all products while we
added you know advanced safety features
to it and those are the things started
if we look at a short term it's not
necessary help us in you know you know
you know typical like fundraising things
or that right but that's the right thing
to do and that's what we did it and with
bracket in there that we don't know all
the time what is the right thing to do
right we try we learn we failed and we
correct them but at least one thing we
know is what is the wrong thing to do
not to do and what about yes if the
vehicle is not safe we should have put
on the street right dad and we should
correct any mistake that we found as
soon as possible so I think that is one
of the guiding principle for Ellis for
me as a person and hopefully for my team
till I go forward and passion is another
thing that I think that really matters
yeah when it comes to entrepreneurship
or that you know someone can follow what
is the hottest trend and suffer ever
since dad or someone can really follow
their passion enjoying it ever since I
think entrepreneurship to me that is not
measured by you know whether it's a
fuzzy you know globe glamorous CEO or
founder or dad
pronoun trip is not measured by whether
it's a billion-dollar company or how
much you earn from that it's really
measured by itself you know satisfaction
and also measured by the the impact that
each of the personal issue of the
company each of the role in the team
that dad made and that to me that abrino
matters a lot
the and that's what we believe as well
and then immersed with square people and
that that I benefited a tongue off I
think the you know life is a learning
life is a learning process life is a
journey of absorbing good things that
get rid of the bad things and that I
learn a lot you know be at the right
place and working in the industries or
stuff that you're passionate and also
just be immersed with squared people yes
something that I think it's very helpful
when it comes to your children ship and
entrepreneur's that if one character if
you know or maybe you guess this is
actually very lonely that they're you're
you're by yourself in many cases there
are tough decisions there are tough
times that even sometimes the investor
is not fully alive with you right some
of the team is now you know necessary
agree upon so the lonely moment that you
know and there are always key decision
to be made and in those case that the
great mentors that I had in the past
that I learned from the great mentors
that gave me you know the guiding
principles nobody can tell everyone that
how to live their life but a good a lot
of the principles that does apply so we
I benefited a lot from that and I think
that that's one of the suggestions I
would you know give reiieve any anyone
ask me that what are the things that
advisors I would get and that's my one
of my advices to kill a Yantra preneur
whoever it is and the last piece that
we're very proud that you know the
Stanford as a school is our investor the
engineering school is our investor the
business school is our investor the law
school is our investor and star X is our
investor but we're not allowed to
operate here yeah that we respect the
schools
I think there are many other
considerations but I do hope that lime
you all will have the opportunity to
serve the community here